[Musique]
un 31 mars à l'âge de 24 ans je me suis
questionné sur l'utilité de vivre
à force d'avoir la main lourde comme on
dit j'ai droit qu'à la souffrance et à
la perdition
ce 31 mars l'a fait déjà 48 heures que
je suis au lit incrusté dans le matelas
imaginez une chambre dans la pénombre
totale car le moindre rayon de lumière
m'agresse
incapable de me traîner jusqu'au frigo
trop faible pour les réchauffer un plat
dans le micro-ondes
des sueurs froides m'inquiètent j'ai le
cœur qui lâche les idées noires
envahissent
bientôt 10 ans maintenant que je ne vis
plus je survis
ma vie n'est en fait que de blackout
successives j'attrape mon portable pour
retrouver trace de ce que j'ai pu faire
j'ai si peur de me confronter à la
réalité
qu'est-ce que j'ai bien pu faire encore
j'apprends que les personnes présentes à
la soirée ont agité une canette de bière
devant mes yeux pour m'attirer jusqu'à
mon lit
l'image peut reluisante de l'âne et de
sa carotte
il n'y a plus que l'alcool qui me fait
mettre un pied devant l'autre
définitivement l'alcool dicte de ma vie
c'est là que j'entends la porte d'entrée
claquée
c'est
j'avais le mécaniquement un xanax pour
affronter la situation ça apaisera aussi
ma gueule de bois
je vois la poignée de ma chambre se
tourner et apparaît un visage lumineux
celui de ma maman
elle s'assait au pied de mon lit ne
regarde se croisent
elle sait
et là d'une voix calme elle lâche une
phrase dont je me souviendrai toute ma
vie
Baptiste
as-tu songé aux alcooliques anonymes
flashback il y a 20 ans à Londres je
suis bien loin d'y penser aux
alcooliques anonymes
j'ai une enfance tellement heureuse je
suis l'aîné d'une famille de cinq
garçons dont un frère jumeau et tous les
matins après un bon bol de porridge je
fonçais de mon petit uniforme et
j'allais m'installer au fond du bus
scolaire qui venait jusqu'au pas de la
porte
dans le système éducatif anglais nous
emplois du temps étaient personnalisés
donc on soit bon en maths en physique
théâtre poterie tout était adapté
moi je me suis naturellement tourné vers
le sport le foot dont je suis passionné
en Angleterre j'étais valorisé pour qui
j'étais je pouvais exprimer toute mon
unicité
mais maman a aussi voulu qu'on ait une
éducation à la française alors pour ma
sixième on est rentré en France
j'ai vécu cette rupture comme un
arrachement à mon monde idéal
je me suis retrouvé sur un banc à
écouter le professeur sur son estrade et
l'on attendait de moi à ce que je rentre
dans le moule
des premiers signes d'alerte sont
arrivés les premières manifestations de
mon profil anxieux et hypersensible
j'ai vécu mes premières crises
d'angoisse à l'âge de 12 ans les
premières insomnies
je suis même tombé gravement malade j'ai
été atteint d'une pneumonie qui m'a
écarté des cours pendant 8 mois
mes poumons ont été attaqués signe que
j'ai tout fait
manifestation physique d'un mal-être
psychologique mais à l'époque je n'ai
pas les mots pour exprimer cette
souffrance alors je me suis tue
et puis il parlait de ses émotions
c'était faire à votre faiblesse alors
j'ai suivi comme un bon petit soldat
tout allait changer lorsque j'ai
rencontré l'alcool
cette première rencontre s'est faite à
l'âge de 14 ans j'étais dans la rue
avant une soirée et un pote me tend une
bouteille de rosé
j'avais ce désir d'appartenir à ce
groupe c'est vrai que mon
hypersensibilité s'exprime aussi par un
fort désir d'être aimé d'être reconnu
j'ai dit oui
j'ai dit oui à cette première gorgée et
instantanément l'angoisse est volatilisé
on peut dire que j'ai commencé à boire
comme tout le monde mais j'ignorais que
mes cellules n'étaient pas celles de
tout le monde
mon cerveau daddict ritualisent
énormément les choses alors si je passe
ma première soirée sous alcool et
qu'elle se déroule bien j'ai envie de
reproduire ce schéma inlassablement
le Beach drinking est devenu un art de
vivre le before un passage
incontournable
la véritable question
c'est pourquoi je bois
pour les effets bien sûr parce que le
goût
honnêtement
l'alcool m'a apporté tellement de choses
positives au début
je retrouvais des émotions enfantines
oubliées je me sentais libre loin de la
pression scolaire et familiale avec un
verre à la main je me sentais viril
immortel prêt à croquer la vie à pleines
dents
je pouvais être drôle je masquais mon
hypersensibilité je comblai mon manque
de confiance en moi allez un dernier
petit shot pour aller oser parler à
cette fille galop au bout du bar
je suis devenu un autre un super
Baptiste doté de plein de super pouvoirs
mais qui finalement est à l'opposé de ma
véritable nature
pudique
introvertie peur du regard de l'autre
un super Baptiste capable de dire des
phrases comme la pression je ne la subis
pas je la bois
dans mes années lycées je considérais
qu'il existait deux catégories de
personnes dans la vie
ceux qui profitent des bonnes choses les
buveurs d'alcool et ceux qui sont ternes
et tristes les buveurs
ah bon tu bois pas mais tu es malade
comment tu fais la fête tu dois
carrément t'ennuyer non
je méprisais ce qui ne voulait pas faire
la fête selon mes règles
et je repense à la phrase de ma maman
as-tu songé aux alcooliques anonymes
à 19 ans
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on me dise que
l'alcool ne détend pas il anesthésie
à 19 ans je reçois un appel de papa qui
me dit je pars faire un jogging je
reviens pour le dîner
une heure plus tard je reçois un nouvel
appel de papa je décroche et c'est pas
lui au bout du fil
c'est un autre homme
qui me dit vous êtes le dernier numéro
composé venez vite il y a eu un problème
alors j'attrape maman qui était dans sa
chambre et non se dirige vers le lieu
indiqué et là je découvre mon papa sur
le dos sur le bitume intubé le SAMU en
train de lui faire des massages
cardiaques
c'est bien la première fois que j'ai vu
mon papa dans un état si fragile si
humain
les secours sont arrivés trop tard j'ai
perdu mon papa du jour au lendemain
alors qu'il était en pleine santé
il avait 44 ans
j'ai bu pour trois raisons
la première c'est qu'à 19 ans je n'ai
aucune conscience de ce que c'est la
mort pour moi papa est parti en vacances
il va revenir après la fin de l'été
alors je reste dans mes mécaniques
habituelles
et la troisième c'est que lui plus là
lui qui représente la figure autoritaire
de la famille lui qui impose les règles
à la maison et bien je peux enfin m'a
donné à mon dieu
mon Dieu qui est l'alcool
tu songer aux alcooliques anonymes
mais pourquoi est-ce que j'aurais pensé
aux alcooliques anonymes je ne peux pas
être un alcoolique
à 20 ans j'aurais bien aimé qu'on me
dise que l'alcoolisme ne discrimine
absolument personne et encore moins les
jeunes
mais c'est vrai comment concevoir ce
terme alcoolique un mot aussi lourd en
représentation négative parce que pour
moi je suis jeune je profite de la vie
je fais la fête
tiens il est 11h du mat c'est bien
l'heure de l'apéro quelque part dans le
monde
à 20 ans quand je visualise ce terme je
vois quelqu'un de fragile un faible sans
volonté quelqu'un de violent
je vois un homme qui qui doit prendre sa
flash de whisky tous les matins pour
supprimer les tremblements je vois un
sans-abri qui au coin de la rue ou une
femme qui néglige ses enfants
l'alcoolisme c'est pour les vieux cons
certainement pas pour moi
moi je m'arrête quand je veux moi je
gère
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on me dise que
l'alcoolisme est une maladie et pas un
manque de volonté
à 22 ans mes amis ma famille commence à
me faire des reproches alors un soir
j'ai essayé de me contrôler
je suis arrivé le temps du Before mais
arrivé en boîte mes promesses se sont
rétamées au sol
dans la pénombre de la boîte mes potes
ne sont plus là pour me surveiller alors
je fais des allers-retours entre le bar
et les enceintes
encore aujourd'hui je me demande
et si je n'avais bu que du jus d'orange
quand je bois je vis dans un monde de
bisounours à mon naïf tiens un homme
m'offre un whisky coca
de l'alcool gratuit mais c'est le Saint
Graal
il n'y a pas de meilleur cadeau que tu
puisses me faire
suite à ce verre je perds le total
contrôle de mon corps
il me ramène chez lui
il me viole
je savais qu'un enfant pouvait se faire
violer par un homme je savais qu'une
femme sous l'action de la violence
pouvait se faire violer par un homme
j'ignorais qu'un homme
hétérosexuel pouvait se faire agresser
par un autre homme
alors j'aurais tant aimé qu'on me dise
que je peux être une victime parce que
je suis bourré il m'a choisi parce que
je suis bourré
je suis tombé dans une profonde
dépression je suis allé consulter un
psychiatre qui m'a prescrit des
antidépresseurs sans jamais qu'on évoque
ensemble ma consommation d'alcool
l'alcool est un dépresseur contrairement
à ce que l'on pourrait croire il nourrit
les angoisses il favorise les états
dépressions
alors si je mélange alcool et
médicaments
cocktail explosif
j'ai fini par boire en cachette je
mentais la honte et la culpabilité me
rongeait je buvais quand même
seul je me suis senti si seul
alors alcool festif alcool mondain
pour moi l'alcool est un liant social
qui a fini par m'isoler
je reviens à ce fameux 31 mars à 24 ans
maman pousse la porte de ma chambre
et pour la première fois elle me voit
tel que je suis elle ne me juge pas elle
ne me fait pas de leçon de morale elle
admet enfin que son fils est malade et
qu'il a besoin d'aide
sa phrase c'est certainement sa façon à
elle de me dire
qu'elle veut que je vive
et moi ai-je le droit de m'autoriser à
vivre
boire ou ne pas boire ça revient à
choisir entre la mort et la mort soit je
bois et j'en meurs sois j'arrête et l'on
me retire la seule béquille qui me fait
vivre
c'est le lien maternel qui a été ma
bouée de sauvetage l'amour cette énergie
qui terrasse la mort m'a sauvé
on parle souvent du fameux déclic comme
si du jour au lendemain on se réveillait
et on avait tout compris
en fait c'est une succession de toute
petite prise de conscience qui amène à
une décision finale
le déclic est un processus où l'on finit
par accepter de l'aide
j'admets ne plus pouvoir tout faire tout
seul
et je fais taire mon orgueil maladie
la chose la plus courageuse au monde
finalement c'est d'oser regarder ces
vulnérabilités en face
entre l'eau de vie et la vie j'ai choisi
mes trois premiers mois d'abstinence je
les ai vécues dans un brouillard comme
la traversée d'une petite mort
en gueule de bois comme si j'avais bu
mais pas une seule goutte d'alcool dans
le sang
et puis un jour je suis sorti de la
maison
j'ai levé les yeux
et j'ai vu un grand ciel bleu
pas même une trace d'avion dans le ciel
signe d'une absence d'obstacle
je vais aller me promener dans un parc
ça sentait l'odeur de l'herbe coupée je
me suis assis sur un banc et c'était
rugueux sous ma peau
quand j'ai décidé d'arrêter
d'anesthésier mes souffrances j'ai pris
conscience que j'anesthésiais aussi mes
joies
c'est donc ça le bonheur que j'ai touché
du doigt sur mon banc parce que si c'est
ça j'en veux encore
et je vous le promets vivre sobre ce
n'est pas mourir d'ennui
aux alcooliques anonymes j'ai pris
conscience que je n'étais pas seul que
je n'étais pas un échec que je n'étais
pas un digne
j'ai surtout pris conscience que
l'alcool m'avait menti
l'alcool m'a promis d'être heureux j'ai
terminé dépressif
l'alcool m'a promis de me donner du
courage j'ai eu peur de tout
l'alcool m'a promis d'être une
récompense j'ai eu droit à la souffrance
l'alcool m'a promis de me donner
confiance en moi j'ai perdu tout estime
de moi
l'alcool m'a promis d'être libre
je suis devenu son esclave
c'est l'abstinence qui m'offre tout ce
que l'alcool me promettait
la reconstruction n'est pas linéaire
j'attendais une pilule magique mais non
est-ce que je préfère la mer ou la
montagne la viande ou le poisson les
brunes ou les blondes
je ne sais rien
c'est terrifiant
tout est à reconstruire
est-ce que l'abstinence allait régler
tous mes problèmes
ce qui est certain c'est que j'ai dû me
rencontrer véritablement sans masque
j'ai osé le faire grâce à une rencontre
Judith losman fondatrice de la littéraux
thérapie thérapie par l'écriture et qui
aujourd'hui la coïnutrice de mon
histoire
l'écriture m'a sauvé la vie
et Judith m'a autorisé à être plus doux
avec moi-même dans ce monde régi par le
perfectionnisme la performance la data
nous ne sommes pas des machines
nous sommes des êtres humains un parfait
doté d'émotions
j'ai accepté mon hypersensibilité
avec un peu plus d'amour propre on a
moins de raison de se détruire
pour définitivement éradiquer la
dépression j'ai dû trouver sens à ma vie
je suis abstinent depuis plus de 7 ans
et je suis impatient expert en
addictologie
j'accompagne des personnes qui souffrent
d'addiction je transforme mes
expériences douloureuses comme outil
pour les autres et ainsi je remplis mon
vide intérieur autrement que par
l'alcool
l'alcoolisme n'a pas détruit ma vie il
la réorienté
parce que mon alcoolisme a été le prix à
payer pour accepter de vivre avec
moi-même
et vous
qu'est-ce qui va réorienter votre vie
merci
[Applaudissements]